انتقل للدكتور لقاء مكي من الدوحه الباحث
الاول بمركز الجزيره للدراسات اهلا بك
معنا لماذا هذه المشاركه العربيه في هذه
القوه اقتصرت فقط على
البحرين نعم هي حقيقه الملاحظه الابرز في
تشكيل هذه القوه انه خلت من اي دوله على
ساحل البحر الاحمر وتحديدا مصر
والسعوديه خلو القوه من هاتين الدولتين هو
مؤشر واضح على ان الولايات المتحده فشلت
في ان تحشد الدولتين في ضمن قوه الردع
للحوثي وهذا الامر في الواقع يعني ربما
يؤشر على امكانيات الولايات المتحده
المحدوده لا سما وان هذه القوه كان المقدر
لها 39 دوله نحن الان امام ع دول فقط هذا
الامر في الواقع كله يعني يؤكد ان هذه
القوه ما زالت محدوده حتى وشاركت البحرين
بسبب فقط
بسبب وجود الاسطول الخامس فيها الامريكي
وبالتالي وجودها امر يعني لا يتعلق
بقدرتها على المشاركه وانما وجودها لغرض
التنسيق بين القوه وبين الاسطول الخامس
الامريكي هذا الامر هو الذي يجعل وجود هذا
هذا الاسطول الكبير او هذه القوه في البحر
الاحمر في الواقع محصور في اطار البحر ولا
يستطيع ان يستفيد من القدرات اللوجستيه
للدول
المشاطئة
اعتقد ان اولا السعوديه كانت في حاله حرب
مع الحوثي وهي انهت عمليا حاله الحرب منذ
مده ودخلت في مرحله تسويات وتركت الامر
للحكومه اليمنيه الشرعيه للتفاوض مع
الحوثي وكذلك هناك مفاوضات بين السعوديه
وبين الحوثي على تامين الحدود اعتقد ان
ايضا السعوديه لا تريد الان ان تكون جزء
من اي سياق قتال في المنطقه او اي امتداد
للصراع في غزه الى المنطقه لا سيما مع
ايران او مع اذرع ايران في المنطقه
السعوديه لديها رؤيه
ومقاربتها الداخلي ما يتعلق بالمستقبل
وهذا معلن كله من خلال الاعلانات السعوديه
المتكرره انها لا تريد الدخول في اي سياق
قتالي او حربي في على حدودها هذا الامر هو
الذي جعلها تتصالح مع ايران وهو الذي
جعلها تعلن عن انهاء حاله الحرب في اليمن
وبالتالي يعتقد انها لا يمكن ان تنساق الى
حاله حرب هي ليست معنيه فيها لان التجاره
او تهديدات الحوثي لا تشملها ولا تشمل
السفن المتعلقه سفنها يعني اذا سفنها اصلا
بعد باب ال المندب تعبر من جده الى السويس
مباشره نعم برايك دكتور
اللقاء هذه الدول المشاركه ما
حدود المهام التي
ستنجز من خلال هذه القوه او هذا التحالف
الدولي
طبعا هو مبدئيا حسب ما يشاع او ما قيل حتى
الان عن ها القوه انها ستحمي السفن الماره
عبر باب المندب قوه
مرافقه نعم هذا ما اعلن يضا يعني من من
الواجب انه في حال تعرض هذه
السفن التجاريه الى اي تهديد من قبل
الحوثي لا سما المتجهه الى اسرائيل فهذه
القوه يجب ان تدافع عنها لكن الاشكاليه
هنا هل ستقوم هي ايضا بمهاجمه مواقع حوثيه
لا سما تلك المواقع التي يطلق منها
الصواريخ او المسيرات هذا امر في الواقع
يعني ما زال محل تساؤل لان اي مهاجمه لهذه
المواقع الحوثيه قد يقود الى عمليه تصعيد
للصراع في في عنق البحر الاحمر اي في ماب
المندب وربما سيشمل ذلك السفن المتجهه الى
كل انحاء العالم يعني ليست السفن المتجهه
ال اسرائيل هذا التصعيد لا تريد الولايات
تم تشكيلها من اجل ردع الحوثيين ام من اجل
اعاده الثقه مع الشركات التجاريه وشركات
التامين هو حقيقه عمليه الردع قد تقود
يعني حسب المفهوم الامريكي قد تجبر الحوثي
حينما يرى هذه القوه البحريه الهائله على
شواطئ اليمن قد تجبر على انه يكف عن ضرب
السفن جميعا المتجهه الى اسرائيل او
سواها قوه الردع نعم هي حقيقه مدمره هذا
النمط من القوه اسطو الوحده الامريكي يكفي
او حامله الطائرات لكن من واقع التجارب مع
الحوثي في الواقع اعتقد ان هذا لن يكون
سبب مباشر لحمله
على تفادي ضرب اي سفينه او الرجوع عن
تهديدات السابقه هنا ننا سنكون يعني ستكون
هذه القوه ولا سما قيادتها الامريكيه امام
اشكاليه الرد العنيف على الحوثي الرد
العنيف سيعني تصعيد الحرب
الاقليميه بالضبط بالضد بما تريده واشنطن
هذا ان حدث ربما سيؤدي الى مزيد من
التصعيد في البحر الاحمر وهنا سيكون
المساله اكثر تعقيدا من ذي قبل ولكن
الحوثيون يقولون الممرات امنه الا على
اسرائيل وبالتالي هل تمر من جديد شركه
عفوا سفن تجاريه باتجاه
اسرائيل طبعا هو مبدئيا هذا هو تصريح
الحوثي انه السفن فقط المتجهه الى اسرائيل
لكن تعرفين ان راس المال جبان يعني هذه
السفن التجاريه تحمل شحنات ضخمه يوميا من
باب البند كل يوم يمر حوالي 10 مليار
دولار او بضائع بقيمه 10 مليار دولار منها
حوالي سته الى 7 مليون برميل نفط هذا
الامر يجعل السفن الكبيره المحمله بشحنات
ضخمه من المواد المختلفه تتجنب المرور من
هناك لان لانه في حاله حرب هناك حاله حرب
حتى لو لم تكن متجه الى اسرائيل لكنها قد
تصاب باي طائره او صاروخ ربما عرضي طبعا
هذه قد تكون حاله استثنائيه لكنها قد تحدث
وبالتالي نجد ان شركات التامين رفعت
التامين على على
السفن المار عبر البحر الاحمر الى 200%
وهذا الامر ارهق ميزانيات الشركات الكبرى
و برتش بتروليوم بالمناسبه اليوم ايضا او
امس اعلنت توقف رحلاتها عبر البحر الاحمر
هنا نحن نتحدث عن طريق تجاري اساسي في
العالم اصبح في حاله نزاع حربي لذلك اعتقد
حتى السفن غير المشموله بالتهديد ستحاول
تجنبه وهذا امر طبيعي ومتوقع في كل
الاوقات كل ما يجري من تصعيد في البحر
الاحمر كيف انعكس على
الاسواق الحقيقه اولا احنا كما اشرت 100%
زادت نسبه التامين
والتجاره عموما تتاثر من خلال
رفع اسعار الشحن بمعنى ان نسب التامين
المرتفعه ستؤثر على التسعيرات النهائيه
للمنتجات الواصله هذا سيؤدي الى رفع
الاسعار الى التضخم وقرت اوروبا كما
تعرفون وهي المستفيد الاكبر من التجاره
عبر البحر الاحمر يعني فيها من التضخم ما
يكفي بلا سما بسبب الحرب الاخرانيه ايضا
شحنات النفط احنا نتكلم عن شحنات نفط
ستتاح ح لان ستمر عبر راس الرجاء الصالح
وستستغرق اربع اسابيع اضافيه للوصول الى
وجهات النهائيه ونحن في موسم شتاء هذا
سيؤثر على سلاسل الامداد سيؤثر على وصول
الشحنات في وقتها المحدد واحن نتحدث عن
اوروبا كملجا اخير او مستفيد اخير من
الشحنات اسرائيل التي تستورد نصف
احتياجاتها عبر البحر الاحمر الان اصبحت
لا تستورد اي شيء لا يصلها اي شيء كما قال
رئيس ميناء
اللاد حوالي اسبوع ان الميناء اصبح الان
شبه فارغ من السفن هذا الامر في الواقع
سيؤثر بشكل مباشر على اسرائيل بشكل خاص
وعلى الدول الاوروبيه ايضا وط على قناه
السويس التي ستتاح بشكل مباشر من توقف
السفن للمرور عبرها